PROFESSOR, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
THE ANALYSIS.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: IMPEACHMENT
HEARINGS ARE SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE
EVIDENCE OF PROFOUND WRONGDOING.
INSTEAD, OVER AND OVER THEY
REVEALED ONLY THE THOUGHT
PROCESS OF PROFESSIONAL
BUREAUCRATS.
WHAT THEY ASSUMED WHAT THEIR
PRIORITIES ARE, WHAT THEY TOLD
EACH OTHER.
THAT'S NOT THE SAME AS EVIDENCE
OF A CRIME, AS CONGRESSMAN MIKE
TURNER EXPLAINED.
>> DR. HILL, YOU HAVE PROVIDED
ME THE GREATEST PIECE OF
EVIDENCE THAT'S BEFORE US TO
ILLUSTRATE THE PROBLEM WITH
HEARSAY.
SO, YOU SAID BASED ON QUESTIONS
AND STATEMENTS, I HAVE HEARD, NO
MATTER HOW CONVINCED WE ARE,
DR. HILL, NO MATTER HOW MUCH WE
BELIEVE WE KNOW THAT WHAT WE'VE
HEARD IS TRUE, IT IS STILL JUST
WHAT WE'VE HEARD.
>> Tucker: SO DEMOCRATS HAD A
RESPONSE TO TURNER.
THEY DIDN'T PRODUCE BETTER
EVIDENCE.
THAT WOULD BE TOO SIMPLE PRAYER
THEY CALLED HIM A SEXIST.
CONGRESSMAN SEAN PATRICK MALONEY
PROTECTED HALE SAYING SHE WAS
THE VICTIM OF MANSPLAINING.
>> DR. HILL, THAT WAS SOME EPIC
MANSPLAINING, AND I WANT THE
ASSEMBLY TO KNOW IT WAS
INAPPROPRIATE.
I RESPECT YOUR FORBEARANCE.
>> Tucker: WHAT A TOTAL
MEDIOCRITY OF THAT GUY IS.
KEVIN BRUCE IS NOT MEDIOCRITY,
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
ONE OF OUR FAVORITE TO GET
TAMMY BRUCE ON FOX NATION, SHE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE AN
ARGUMENT.
IT SEEMS LESS THAN THAT.
>> IT'S LESS THAN THAT.
WHAT I WILL DO HERE IS I WILL DO
SOME TAMMY-SPLAINING
SOME TAMMY-2PLAINING
SOME TAMMY-2 SAINING
SOME TAMMY-2 SHENING
SOME TAMMY-2 SHEDING
SOME TAMMY-2 SHED SG
SOME TAMMY-2 SHED SOME LIGHT ON
WHAT HAPPENED THERE APPEARED WE
KNOW THESE TELEVISED HEARINGS
ARE MEANT FOR THE VIEWER, RIGHT?
THIS IS THE ONE CHANCE FOR THE
REPUBLICANS TO EXPLAIN, THEY ARE
LIMITED AND HAVE TO ASK FOR
PERMISSION ABOUT WHO THEY CAN
ASK FOR AND EVEN WHAT TO ASK AND
SAY, ET CETERA.
SO THIS IS A CHANCE FOR IT TO BE
MADE CLEAR THAT THIS HAS BEEN AN
EXERCISE IN HEARSAY, IN GOSSIP,
IN ROOM AIR.
THAT'S WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
HAVE SEEN IS WELL AND THEY'VE
REALIZED THAT THEY DON'T LIKE
THAT AT ALL.
SO THIS IS, OF COURSE, WHAT
MAN'S
MANSPLAINING IS COME UP TREATING
HER LIKE A CHILD, AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT MALONEY ENDED UP
DOING WHILE COMPLETING,
COMPLAINING ABOUT TAYLOR.
TALKING TO HER AS IF SHE WAS
HARMED.
WE SAW THIS WITH YOVANOVICH AS
WELL, TALKING TO HER LIKE SHE'S
A SOFT LITTLE PEDAL, A
WALLFLOWER THE CORNER, SORRY YOU
HAD TO ENDURE THAT.
THIS IS ANOTHER POWERFUL WOMAN.
SHE KNOWS WHAT SHE'S DOING.
I DON'T THINK HER FEELINGS WERE
HURT.
BY THE WAY, TAYLOR AND OTHERS --
THEY ARE TALKING THIS WAY TO
VIRTUALLY EVERYONE.
THE FACT IS, IF WE ARE IN THE
ARENA KAMIL WE ARE GOING TO BE
TREATED EQUALLY.
THAT WAS THE CRIME.
MALONEY THROUGH THIS PROCESS THE
TAKES HER BY THE HAND, HOLDING
HER HAND LIKE A LITTLE GIRL,
TAKING HER ALONG -- I MEAN, THAT
IS THE SEXISM.
THAT IS THE INSULT WHERE ALL THE
MALE WITNESSES FACE THE SAME
THING AND NOBODY WAS WORRIED
ABOUT THEIR MENTAL STATE.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY RIGHT.
REALLY, WANTED THE MOST
PATRONIZING THINGS I CAN
IMAGINE.
THANK YOU FOR POINTING THAT OUT.
>> THEY MEANT IT TO BE ABOUT
SEXISM BUT I THINK IT'S TURNING
AROUND ON THE VERY HARDLY.
>> Tucker: WRIGHT, TELLS YOU
MORE ABOUT THEM.
GOOD TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.